Voiceover: You are given
the following starting
numbers and rules for
two sequences of numbers.
The first sequence, Sequence x,
starting number should be one,
and then the rule is add one.
Sequence y, starting
number should be five,
and then the rule should be add five.
Fill in the table with the
first three terms of x and y.
Then plot the ordered pairs (x,y)
on the graph below.
So let's see, Sequence x.
They say, the starting number,
the starting number should be one.
So the starting number is one,
and then the rule, to
get to the next number,
you just add one.
So, one plus one is two.
Two plus one is three.
Fairly straight forward.
Now, let's look at Sequence y.
They're saying the starting
number should be five.
Starting number five,
and then the rule is,
to get the next term, we just add five.
So, five plus five is ten,
ten plus five is fifteen.
Now they want us to plot these things.
Let's see, we plot them as ordered pairs,
so we're going to have the point (1,5).
When x is one, y is five.
We see that there, x is one, y is five.
When x is two, y is ten.
When x is two, y is ten,
and then when x is three, y is fifteen.
When x is three, y is fifteen,
and wee see that.
For every one we move to the right,
for every one we increase
in the horizontal direction,
every one we increase in
x, we increase five for y.
We increase one for x,
we increase five for y.
So now we just have one
last thing to answer.
The terms in Sequence y are blank,
times the terms in Sequence x.
So you immediately see, this term, five,
is five times one.
Ten is five times two.
Fifteen is five times
three, and it makes sense.
You started five times higher,
and here you added one
each time, and we see that
visually right over here,
we add one each time, while here we add
five times as much each time.
We add five each time.
The terms in Sequence y are five
times the terms in Sequence x.
We got it right.